can someone remind me how do I work out
an average don't worry about these
particular numbers just averages in
general I know it's what do you reckon
add all the numbers together and then
divide by however many there are which
in this case is three okay now I think
we're generally okay with dividing
numbers but it ends up being the adding
the first step that News mentioned
that's the hard part right what's hard
about adding these three numbers
together though is they all have
different denominators which is slightly
gross that's actually the design of this
question so we can do something to
change the appearance of the numbers so
they do have the same tuner what are we
going to do Emily oh now you could turn
any of these into percentages you also
could change any of them into decimals
but I'm going to suggest for these
particular numbers that will probably be
less helpful rather than more helpful
can you know it's just to me why even
though we could I'd prefer not to
why did Jessica you can't kind of had
not really what do you think here
you're gonna be there for a very long
time I'd see if you keep right and one
we call this by the way when the decimal
it just it's recurring very good what at
this one over seven
it also records over and over and over
again in fact this one over here is the
only one that stops what's it called
when it stops us out to the T it
terminates like a train right so 0.25
that one's okay but the rest of them
look kind of gross so I'm going to
suggest we actually keep them in
fractional and what can we do to help in
it excellent so when we have a look at
the denominators the denominators the
part that matters the denominators the
part that makes it hard actually we want
a number that is a common multiple of 4
and 3 and 7 has anyone worked out what
it is I say it again here 84 when 84
come from by the way if you take all
three of these and multiplying them
together you'll get 84 okay now that's
not the only way but it is an easy way
to work it out Lois do you have a
thought or a suggestion 42 is 42 a
multiple of it's a multiple of three and
seven but not a multiple of four is it
which is close yep
so before you get there before I take
your different way can we finish this
first way and then we'll come and see if
it other ways more helpful let's try and
get these out of 44 shall we
that's right 84 what I multiply this by
to get it over 84 the top and the bottom
have to be all multiplied by a number 21
by the way do you see where 21 comes
from in the question it's the other two
denominators right so that's going to be
21 over happy with that I want this one
to be over 84 as well what I multiply
the top and the bottom by 28 which I get
from the the two denominators what is 2
times 28 56
oops 56 it's very messy and then the
last one to get that over 84 what do I
multiply by 12 right 5 times 560 okay
you can add those and then what was the
thing that inertia said right at the
beginning but after I've got the sum
what I do I'm gonna take all of these
guys and divide by 3 very good and I'm
actually pretty content that you guys
will be able to do that I just wanted to
get you over the hump a lot of you
couldn't get to this step and that was
the challenge you can add those divided
by a forward divided by 3 and then you
get in on something has someone got an
answer for question 2 has someone got a
final line the month 8 over 5 can I get
any agreement or disagreement with that
do you only get a different answer no
Lee is nodding along ok aired over 5
this just takes me to perseverance this
one you can see I've done the first step
for you that's a half and then you just
keep on going okay last one did anyone
get any answer for the last one I see
one hand two three Liat did you get an
answer you want to share with us
you got four now who agrees there for ya
happy times okay really good it is four
I wonder if any of you remember when we
were back at percentages one of the nice
things about of is it means
multiplication and multiplication you
can switch order do you remember that
you can switch the order around so 16
percent is really 16 what is percent an
abbreviation of doesn't remember percent
it's
it's out of a hundred right so that's
out of a hundred and then you
multiplying that by 25 and you can just
change this order right so it's the same
as 25% of 16 do you remember doing this
this is a while ago which is 4 which is
a lot easier to work out